[Music]
well what do you know top ten
hand-to-hand fights in anime volume two
blew up
I think everyone's raring for more anime
fight scenes that involve good ol fists
so here we are I heard you and if that
last video wasn't enough to quench your
thirst for anime brawling then this
video will be perfect for you after
having gone through more than a dozen
hand-to-hand fights in anime why not
come back for more I mean throughout its
colorful history anime has more than its
fair share of hand-to-hand fights to
keep the list going for many volumes so
for now we take a look at ten more
amazing instances that show that anime
is just not all about swords and guns
[Music]
now here's an anime that you may not
have heard of and I don't blame you know
in isn't exactly the most popular show
in the Shonan dominated mid-2000s but
its twelfth episode gave us this gem of
a battle between garasu and [ __ ] oh
it's a classic climactic beat down
between two combatants done in knowing
signature art style now I'd say that the
animation and the overall feel of the
thing can be an acquired taste but few
can undermine the tension surrounding
the whole thing the music helps a lot
too as do the cuts to different scenes
mid-fight for me the fight itself only
tells half the story but with something
like this or would it be surprised if
some people would start thinking
otherwise 9th place on the list is
Nagisa vs. karma I think that this fight
is one of the best ones in assassination
classroom even if you put the
hand-to-hand qualifier away in addition
to it being a great fight as a fight I
also think that the emotions flowing in
this fight really work in its favor too
the fight was back-and-forth at first
with garma giving some painful looking
beat downs on his less physically
inclined opponent nonetheless Nagisa has
heart and you should never count out a
determined fighter in the end karma
concedes defeat in one epic turnaround
until now people still debate on whether
karma let Nagisa win this one or not I
think that the anime is leaning towards
that narrative then again garma is the
better one in terms of actual fighting
but there's no way that another fight
between the two would be that easy to
call
[Music]
in the 8th spot we have Edward Elric
versus greed now the question is which
Edward versus greed fight well the one
from the original FMA a lot of people
sing Brotherhood's praises but I think
that the original FMA had its shining
moments too one such moment is the fight
between Edward and greed in episode 24
it seems to be one of the great underdog
fights in MMA Edward spends most of the
start of this fight getting his ass
kicked thanks to the sudden
transformation of his opponent and the
fast attacks in which the latter came
upon him with the eventual comeback does
begin when Edward forces a fist to fist
deadlock and he finishes the battle with
the good ole stab through the chest not
many remember the original FMA compared
to Brotherhood for this fights really
something to remember it by truly one of
the best fights and moments in that
series
[Applause]
we don't really see a lot of people talk
about Kizuna ichigeki but i think that
it's a nice cool short film that you
guys might want to check out if you've
got some time to spare for me the
highlight of this movie as far as fight
sequences go is the battle between
Kizuna and giant gaga the battle short
but intense and is a nifty example of
the classic David versus Goliath style
fight fast and agile kazoo gnar spends
most of the fight jumping around and
delivering quick strikes while
creatively using the gigantic opponent
as terrain to deliver some more
complicated moves giant Gaga struggles
to catch the tiny opponent and is
finished off by a punch to the forehead
maybe Giants really do have a weak spot
on their foreheads overall the fight
takes a little less than a minute and is
short but sweet
sixth on the list is another moment from
the Cowboy Bebop movie while this movie
sure has its fair share of nice
hand-to-hand combat doesn't it from the
same movie that bought a spike versus
Vincent we get spike versus Elektra
Spike's infiltration mission is off to a
rough start as the immediately comes
face to face with Elektra running into a
woman who engages you in battles that
quickly is tough for our heroes but it
does make for some nice visuals for us
viewers the two go at it with everything
in their disposal which includes punches
kicks and whatever props they can get
their hands on this is certainly an
inferior fight compared to spike versus
Vincent one we see later on in the film
which I've featured in a previous list
by the way nevertheless the short
scuffle does give us an ample appetizer
to the fights that are yet to come in
the very same movie
sometimes you just got to hand it to the
animators don't you they just do their
job too well and turn a nice show into
must-see TV for some parts of the anime
fan base for glide near its moment came
in episode 2 with the battle between
Shuichi and heckuva there's a lot to be
said about the battle itself but the
moment quickly cements itself to the
minds of the Watchers thanks to the
beautiful animation this is something
that you don't see in manga it took up
most of the discussions after the
episode and elevated the show through
the ranks of its peers in the season it
also helps they're given the premise and
the genre of the show fans will be
coming back for more
with glide nears run still ongoing let's
wait and see if more of this will come
our way and I tell you have a good
feeling it probably will the fight put
glieben it on the map of many anime
watches and it's proof of what the power
of animation can have in bringing to
life or even pushing an already good
fight to greater heights
for our fourth-place battle on the list
we have a luffy versus blue no a memory
vault battle often comes with a
memorable reveal and I think that luffy
showing off gear ii in his fight against
blue no makes one of the more epic
scenes in the first 300 or so episodes
of one piece the fight itself isn't too
shabby and I think that both fighters
learn a thing or two following their
skirmish at water 7 it's more so for
Luffy who finds a way to break through
his deck eye and manages to find him on
even terms with soru then comes the
grand finale which is the reveal of gear
2nd a sign of things to come in the
story with luffy's abilities there's
also the nifty detail about gear 3rd
foreshadowing in this battle is
something that you'll come back to you
in catch once you've gotten to the
latter storylines
my hero academia is first season ended
with a banger of a final fight we're at
the cusp of the first season's ending
and what a way to end the up with a
climactic battle to demonstrate why
Almighty is rightfully the world's
mightiest hero the whole sequence
deserves mentioning as oh my didn't win
the fight all on his own like some
invincible anime Superman he had some
help from his students and once all the
distractions had been taken care of it
comes down to all might and nomu despite
all of Nowruz endurance and all might
with declining powers makes quick work
of the villain giving us one of the most
iconic gifts featuring the legendary
hero if you can't get enough of all my
he has a lot of other shining moments
that you might want to see in the videos
of this channel for something that's
flown under the radar for so long Kotori
no ether sure finds no shortage of
amazing fight sequences this time we'll
take a look at the fight between Zhuge
and puppets you got to give kudos to the
animators behind this anime project as a
whole this rooftop fight is really a joy
to watch mainly because of the smooth
animation the various camera cuts and
the sheer effort made in sequencing and
choreography the puppets chase Zhuge one
after another and you can really get
caught in the pacing and how swift
everything is if you're up for some
smooth and slick fighting scenes you're
Dorian or shoot that is an anime that
you should really check out
unfortunately we don't have an English
translated version of it just yet so
you'll have to wait for a while but this
definitely is a series I'll be keeping
an eye on for more amazing fights and
animation sequences
[Music]
dragon brought in general is no stranger
to a lot of great hand-to-hand fighting
with it being a martial arts anime first
and foremost I think that Brodie versus
Gogeta is one of the best fights Dragon
Ball in general has to offer simply
because of how intense and fast pace it
is it takes a certain kind of special to
catch your viewers and immerse them in
the experience of such a fast and hyper
battle seed and this one does it very
very well we all know how strong these
two combatants are so a fight between
them has to have some huge expectations
judging by what I just said a few
moments ago this fight got all
expectations checked and then some they
say that you can learn more about a
person or two by how they fight and that
saying definitely applies to this fight
it's more than lights and fireworks but
of course the spectacular takes center
stage overall this thing is simply a
beauty to watch on the big screen and
seeing as how it captivated me so much I
place this at the top of this list
I hope the list this time managed to
satisfy you in your cravings for
hand-to-hand battles in anime what do
you think about this list do you think I
missed any fights out again that should
have been on it if so let me know in the
comments section below that's got to do
it for this edition of the list but who
knows maybe we can have another one of
these if I see that you guys really love
hand-to-hand combat anyway I'll see you
next time on Vinny tube
[Music]